mark is with us in Delaware hey Mark how
are you I'm doing well Dave how are you
and Chris doing better than we deserve
what's up so I was looking to get some
advice as a first-time homebuyer my wife
and I our babies are 3b which means
we're completely out of that no debt
whatsoever so I thank you for that I'm
the only one working right now my wife
is staying at home with our newborn I
bring home roughly fifty two hundred a
month so I wanted to get some advice as
a first-time homebuyer
what to expect what type of price range
I can look at for my income and
basically what things to look out for in
a house and basically two special advice
on the whole process especially there
everything going on right now if if
maybe I should wait a little bit to buy
what the rider is going on right now to
see if the market drops or I just want
to get your take on that yeah no you
listen let me start off mark by
congratulating you for getting out of
debt and having an emergency fund and
I'll kind of tell you this stuff to
avoid and I can tell you this firsthand
my friend first things first is do not
allow the bank to tell you how much you
qualify for okay okay I'm serious it is
ridiculous how much they'll approve you
for and it can be way out of your price
range so you want to establish what
you're looking for in that dollar amount
number two work with a reputable real
estate agent that's why I highly
recommend our real estate LPS because
you only want to go look at homes in
your price range okay now if you're not
even entertain and I've heard people say
well this one is 20 grand more but we'll
go look we can talk them down don't do
it because you're gonna fall in love
with that house so those are two big
tips and I want you to hold steady at
your dollar amount be very clear it is
your wife planning to go back to work or
she's gonna be at home with the newborn
she says she wants to go back after a
year but I can just tell by how she is
right now right she doesn't go back for
her degree she's gonna want to stay at
home okay now I can tell you this my
third and final tip that I'll turn it
over to Dave find something that you
qualify for based on your income in your
income only that's gonna be absolutely
imperative so you don't feel that
scrunch in that crunch of the pressure
yeah and you know when you do you take
out a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage where
the payment is no more than 1/4 of your
take-home pay and so that's going to put
you in the 150 to 180 price range long
term in terms of the loan amount and add
your down payment to that so that's
gonna put your right around there and
you're gonna be fine but fixed-rate 15
year where the payments no more than 1/4
of your take-home